[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory
and filling in for liv moods is the man
the myth the legend the man behind the
curtain
the man who oversees
all of br betting social
channels social platforms whatever you
want to call it my man sam richmond sam
we all know you are the sharp of the
department you are the sharp of vr
betting
what is your secret my friend
well i don't know if i'm a sharp greg
but i did want to say two things one i
am absolutely honored to be here hosting
the show with you you are the king of
vibe so i'm very very excited to be here
and two this really comes at a perfect
time for me because i suffered the worst
college basketball beat of my life
yesterday with alabama minus three and a
half i'm sure some people who had it in
the comments know the pain and the hurt
that i'm going through right now i am in
mourning but it's also the perfect time
for me to make this transition to
locking in on nba i'm done with college
basketball what better way to start that
than winning some bets tonight let's be
great greg
let's be great in fact and as always
we're here giving out vibes giving out
locks giving out hoodies and jerseys so
get in the comments i need gifts i need
emojis and most importantly
i need winners only please salmon in
fact i'm gonna give out a jersey
right now so i'm on the handy dandy
phone looking for takes uh
looking for good takes and good takes
only i see maxwell rexel in the comments
shout out to you maxwell rexella's
rocking with d book i also see
i also see hold on is this enderman in
the comment shout out to you
intermittent michael michael bolin is in
the comments jake the snake is in the
comments okay here we go i got oh don
odin says booker is hot
and no aiden so i think d book will have
the game high so oh dens you are walking
away
with
the jersey shouts out to you sam are you
ready to get the show like officially
started brother
let's do it i'm really excited man
all right everybody it is tnt basketball
thursday fanduel is boosting the three
by two in both games tonight the
question is will there be two
three-pointers in the first
three minutes of the game
last week the three by two cash sam in
the portland denver game
let's take a look
there it is in the corner nacier little
knocks it down
and uh in fact sam nazir little knocked
both of these down for us cashing the
three by two
early this one this one this one wasn't
a sweater sam this one you didn't have
to really sweat this one this one was
easy uh but today we asked you in
on twitter actually my man sam probably
tweeted this himself we asked you
which three by two will cash tonight is
it the suns taking on the maps or is it
the warriors taking on the pacers sam
here are the results
here are there was there they are sam
this one is really really close i need
everybody to get in the comments and
tell us which 3x2 is a lock but sam
talk to us talk to the people which one
is your favorite
yeah i'm honestly surprised this was so
close one stands out to me very much so
and that is warriors pacers i love this
three by two now i'm going to provide
some groundbreaking analysis you cannot
get this anywhere else
the warriors shoot a lot of
three-pointers um no obviously everyone
knows that but they do they're third in
the league and three-point attempts
whereas the pacers are 23rd and
defending the three-point line and the
warriors you'd expect the numbers to go
up now that clay's back so to get a
really good three-point shooting team
against a team that struggles to defend
the line uh i really like that and the
pacers are kind of middle to pack
themselves shooting threes anyway so
maybe they'll sneak one in for you as
well but uh i love stefan clay to take
care of this early for us
yeah i mean trust in the splash brothers
uh
i'm in the comments right now sam i'm in
the comments looking for takes i got mon
mon two three zero zero ap says pacers
and warriors shout out to you you are
walking away with a hoodie uh i got
i got snoopy snoopy is in the comments
2153 indiana go to state warriors splash
bros shout out to you okay you two are
walking away with hoodies i am
announcing sam we are riding with you
brother
the 3x2 we are all riding as a family is
the golden state warriors and the
indiana pacers so let's all get rich now
moving on sam today we asked you in the
app
who will score more points is it luca
doncic or is it devin booker get in the
comments and tell us what you think at
the end of the game well dm one random
person who guessed correctly and hook
you up with a jersey let's take a look
at the current odds sam what do you
think
so i yeah i really like booker
over luca tonight booker has been going
crazy lately he's hit over 26 and a half
in three straight games luca on the
other side has only hit this number
twice in his last nine games there's
also a little sneaky factor here that i
like a lot i think you look at this and
you see that lucas scored 40 points
yesterday you might say oh this is going
to continue he's going to do it again
but this is the second night of a back
to back he played the most minutes of
any game he's played all season he
played 42 minutes he scored 40 points he
left it all on the court yesterday
asking him to do that again today
against a really good sons team i would
expect he's going to be short on some
jumpers tonight when he does that step
back three um and maybe i'm giving away
i'm picking when this game um but i
think luca gasses out a little bit and
he just he goes under tonight so i like
book
i like that i like that a lot sam uh i'm
going with d
book
over tonight i'm going with d book over
he scored 30 plus in his last three game
he's been on the tear and the sons they
need this game in dallas they need this
game the waiters are on the home stand
uh right now or they're looking to
gather some wins so the sons they need
to continue winning in order to stay the
one seed in the west so i can see them
grabbing this one today uh in dallas so
in order for them to to win i need my
guy d book to score and i can see him
going over 26 and a half points sam i'm
in the comments though i am in the
comments because i want to know what
they are talking about and i got
champions champ cheese in the comments
says luca is doing it so sam i think
they're fading you i said i think
they're saying luca is gonna outscore my
guy devin booker tonight uh shout out to
you champ cheese uh i'm back in the
comments and i see
br betting vr betting says lucas
watching sam fade him and they got a
laughing if they are betting's in the
comments sam uh all right officially
ronald says d book he's hitting 40 plus
easily have a d book
gift in there shout out to you you are
walking away with a hoodie uh remember
after the game remember after the game
we're gonna hit up one person and hook
you up with a jersey so follow us on
socials sam it's my favorite part it's
my favorite part of the show let's talk
major markets money lines against the
spreads and point totals for tonight's
game let's take a look at the odds sam
what do you see
here and what do you
like yeah so i'm just going to keep up
my son's love i really like them tonight
the minus 142 money line
money line seems pretty cheap to me a
little stat for you greg
the suns are 15 and 2 straight up as
road favorites this season they're an
nba best 11 and six against the spread
as road favorites this season so they've
been really good in this spot and again
i think i i'm sorry to disappoint that
commenter who thinks luke is going to go
off or maybe i'll be wrong and he'll be
able to make fun of me but i do think
the back-to-back matters i think he left
it all out there last night 42 minutes
again it's a lot to ask him to do that
again against a really good team i think
the sons of the better team i think it's
a small number i love phoenix tonight
yes sam i'm looking in the comments man
i'm i'm looking in the comments and i'm
just going to go through them giving out
hoodies if i mention your name you're
walking away with a hoodie luca having
30 oh my mama j leno 23 shout out to you
you're walking away with a hoodie g
quinn 26 says nah bro luca going for 33
shouts out to you you're walking away
with a hoodie uh locks underwater says i
like the stats sam he's rocking with
your stat sam shout out to you you are
walking away with hoodie sam you're
walking with sons money line
i'm going to rock with the sun's money
line but i also want to talk warriors
warriors pacers here i i do think the
warriors that that can be a route that
can't be around hurting no sabonis
tonight it can be a route in san
francisco tonight but my thing sam is
when the warriors put in those reserves
are they gonna continue scoring or are
they gonna you know
crumble towards the end of the game but
i feel confident i do feel confident in
the sun's getting a win tonight i i
mentioned it and earlier in the show
when i was talking about d booker uh i
could see them going to dallas today and
and getting this win they need to stack
up some wins february is coming this is
usually uh after the all-star break is
when teams start turning it on and i
think phoenix is trying to do this early
because they know the golden state
warriors are coming and uh the one seat
is very very very important so i'm
rocking with the suns let's move on we
talked major market sam
now let's talk player props uh
it's time for lock or not i'm gonna put
up a prop and i need all of you in the
comments
to get in the comments
and tell us if it's a pro if it's a lot
or it's not sam are you ready
let's go i'm excited man
let's get right to it let's get right to
a prop or not first up first up we have
clay thompson
to have
over 15 and a half points sam it's
sitting at minus 112. talk to me talk to
the people do you like this one is this
a lot or not
well first i just want to say we have
agreed on every pick so far so we're
talking vibes
it's hard to get bigger than that so
love that um and i hope we're gonna keep
it going here
good vibes as always um i i like this
over for clay again we talked about
pacer's not very good defending the
three um clay that obviously helps a guy
like clay out
i think this is a route i think the
warriors get up early this is a good
game for the warriors to get clay really
going against inferior competition who's
missing about three or four of their
best players and i think we've seen
since clay's been back he has not been
afraid shoot the ball we love that we
love clay
i think he's going to go more in the
20-point range which i think he had in
his last game so i am taking the over
here
sam i'm right there with you clay had 21
in his last game i think clay gets in
the groove on the home stand the wares
like i mentioned earlier they're on the
seventh game homestay and i think he
gets in the groove here uh he loves
playing in front of that bay area crowd
you know sam you've been there before
i've been there we know he's going to
put up the shots you just mentioned that
we know he's going to put up the shot so
i love putting my money on klay thompson
here in this spot sitting at -112 give
me the over let's move on sam actually
before we move on
i'm in the comments i gotta give away
another hoodie gotta see if they are
riding with us uh oh i got the lock talk
in the comments winners only shout out
to you brother you guys know how i feel
about winners only austin martell
sam austin martel says clay is going for
20. shout out to you austin martell and
the laptop you two are walking away with
a hoodie uh sam let's move on steph
curry steph curry to have five plus
three pointers is sitting at plus 136
talk to the people sam talk to me do you
like this one is this a lock
or is it not
this is this tough for me um as i'm a
huge deaf guy i even feel like dirty
about saying this in front of you
because i i know you love stuff everyone
loves steph
to me i i can't take the over here he's
only hit over five threes once this
entire month his scoring has also been
down in general since clay has came back
i think he's scored under 20 points in
three straight games but i think the big
factor here for me is i expect this game
to be a blowout again the pacers are
going to be missing some of their key
guys
you're probably going to have the
warriors up 20-25 points heading into
the fourth quarter and if steph hits
you're missing out on
eight minutes of him getting three so uh
i can't get there i would take the under
here
that's facts that is a fact sam you make
great points uh my guy steph hasn't done
this since new year's
you you guys know
how much i love rocking with steph curry
but honestly i i probably wouldn't put
my money on this sam i probably wouldn't
but you mentioned they're taking on the
pacers this one might be a blowout steph
might get hot early who knows if you got
the money
sprinkle it like e40 said if you up on
the week sprinkle something on it maybe
maybe not it but uh
i'm not putting my money on it but let's
move on actually before we move on i
gotta tap into the comments man i gotta
tap into the comments to see what they
are talking about uh i got slaydig88
says
uh hey greg i'm here hi slade dick how
are you doing and then they also said
luca luca is
uh having more points than d book shout
out to you you are walking away with a
hoodie
uh
sam
next up next up
we have
kevon looney my guy kevon looney to have
10 or more rebounds sitting at plus 118
sam talk to me talk to the people do you
like this one or do you not like this
one
yeah this is an interesting one to me
because if you look at his season-long
numbers like he does not average 10
rebounds a game but since draymond's
been out he's hit double-digit rebounds
in three games in a row we talked about
it right the pacers are putting out uh
what i like to call a poverty lineup i
expect them to miss a lot of shots i
expect looney to grab them and clean
them up so sure let's let's we're we're
spreading good warriors vibes let's
let's take the over here let's take ten
plus rebounds for loonie
yeah i'm i'm right here with you
looney's been picking up the slack since
there's been no draymond i mean in the
last three games he's gone tanner plus
uh rebounds no sabonis for the pacers
i'm gonna rock with you over here
as well sam uh
look for looney to be crashing the
boards grabbing those boards down there
uh
in this warriors route you know
reserves in for the pacers i'm rocking
with my guy looney i'm in the comments
though i want to see what you guys are
rocking with i want to see what you guys
are talking about uh
i see hey arnold in the comments uh
i i also see larry hall of fame says
sun's moneyline let's get this money
uh
rich dubs rich dubs here we go like the
bet for looney guys he likes it a lot
snoopy also says it's a lock without dre
um in the game enderman says 13 rebounds
for looney shout out to you guys you
guys are walking away with hoodies uh
sam
it's time to build
it's it's your favorite part of the show
sam i bet you this one is your favorite
part of the show it's time to build the
vr betting custom same game parlay which
you can ride with us on fanduel and
speaking of parlays last week we showed
you
three friends who turned one no they
they turned 50 cents
into
130
000
on a first basket parlay sam this week
we got another one for you guys my guy
micah
dossie
turned 32 cents
into 14
and four hundred dollars on the first
basket parlay there it is right there
sam do you like be honest with me sam we
call you the sharp of the department do
you honestly do you make these on your
uh on your off time i don't but like the
more i see these the more i'm like i i
want to get in like lord i've seen what
you do for others send those good vibes
my way i love it man it is so impressive
i don't even know how people
come up with this like adding porzingis
and holmes and it's just crazy but good
for those people man i love to see the
community win
yes i love to see the community win and
like sam said lord please send those
vibes my way but we need those good
vibes because i'm going to give out our
parlay and i need everybody to get in
the comments and tell me what they think
which legs are locks which legs or not
and tonight we're looking at the sun's
mavericks game in first we're starting
off with mama chris paul
eight or more assists sam talk to me
talk to the people do you like this leg
or do you not
i mean i love it like i feel like
there's we don't even need to talk about
this leg that long i mean if he averages
11. he averages 10 per game he's
averaged 11 this month he's the point
guard he's not gonna leave a game
without eight assists so love this easy
that's that's an easy leg in my mind
sam says this one is easy
uh
let's move on let's talk about
luca doncic sitting at ten or more
rebounds sam talk to me talk to the
people do you like this one
yeah so i i love this one especially
where the value came in for the parlay
because this is the leg that was plus
odds and really turned this parlay from
a plus 200 small hit to a plus a
potential plus 500 hit um sure luca
doesn't average 10 rebounds for the
season but in january he's averaging 11
rounds per game he's hit 10 rebounds in
five of his last six games and only one
he didn't he had nine rebounds so to get
this around even odds with how much he's
doing work on the glass right now i i
love this i think it's a great addition
to the parlay
sam likes it i like it as well let's
move on sam we got devin booker
devin booker
two or more three pointers made in
tonight's ball game sam talk to me
do you like this one or do you not
yeah i mean i hate to i hate to keep
saying the same thing but again i love
this i mean i think especially when you
look at booker he's taken 13 threes in
two of his last three games he's really
putting up from beyond the arc he's
averaging three per game this month uh
to only need two again it just it feels
very easy which it's never easy to hit a
parlay but uh i i love the i love the
value here two threes from devin
love it
the man behind the curtain is what we
call him sam i'm starting to think that
you had your hands on making this parlay
uh but let's move on michael bridges
mikel bridges ten or more points
tonight sam talk to me
do you like this one
yeah i like it again uh and yeah you
peeled back the curtain i did have a
hand in making this parlay so i am a
little bit biased but yeah i mean he
averages 12 a game he's been he's been
scoring again well this month so the
recent trends are in favor we need a
little bit less than his average i
really am high on him as a player in
general i think the sun's played really
well tonight so yeah let's ride with
mikael bridges uh scoring double digits
sam we are riding brother we are riding
let's put up the ticket so we can see
the odds and the totals here if you guys
put a hundred dollars down you will be
walking away with 532
dollars
right there uh
sam
before i get in the comments what are
you grading the parlay
well it feels weird to to grade
something i built but so i'm going to
give an a plus this is the greatest
parley ever built
a plus here
hey i i sam i am feeling the vibes
brother i am filling the vibes uh i'm in
the comments though i'm in the comments
sam's giving us good vibes i'm in the
comments giving us good vibes uh jerry
muss says bridges points is a big gamble
but guess what jerry must i'm sending
you a hoodie i'm sending you a hoodie
and that's not a gamble but uh we take
chances here that's that's what we do we
take our chances and we take our gambles
uh so
i got the spicy angels the spicy angel
also says pass on bridges rebounds sam i
don't even think you had ridge's rebound
did you have bridges
we did not yeah that's a tough look yeah
yeah
yeah spicy angel i was gonna give you a
hoodie brother but uh i don't know about
that one all right here we go i got one
more i'm giving away a jersey here sam
giving away a jersey uh i got
julio hernandez i feel like i gave them
a jersey already before but i'll give
him another one
welcome sam and what's up greg i'm
giving to parliament hey anytime we talk
about cp3 assist it's a lock here's the
point god book will hit over four threes
he's on fire and making a case for not
only all-star but mvp bridges is a lock
for ten points he averages double
figures and will bring it in tonight i'm
riding with this parlay sam julio
hernandez loves your parlay julio thank
you for that take those type of takes
gets jerseys and that's what you are
walking away with
sam
we talked i mean we have you here we we
have you here it's it's such a
an honor and a pleasure for you to be
here on the show with us today but sam
you love talking futures
so we're going to talk mvp
rookie of the year and odds to win it
all we're kicking it off with mvp sam
let's pull up the latest odds what's
your favorite play here sam
yeah again this is this is tough for me
because i'm such a stuffed guy i want to
just say grab the favorite grab steph at
plus 180. but the number kind of worries
me again he's been scoring less since
clay's back i think he's kind of lost a
little bit of control of the narrative
he had it really strong earlier in the
season then he went through a little
slump i obviously expect him to continue
to be great but the number's a little
out of whack for me uh
i have money on one of these guys john
morant i took him at 40 to 1. he's now
14 to one i love morant especially if
the grizzlies can jump up and get a two
or three seed it's going to be hard to
not give him a serious look but i think
my favorite number on the board right
now is is giannis i think he's around
plus 360.
i think the thing that i like most about
this is the bucks quietly are only two
games out of the number one seed in the
east if he's and if he's able to get
them there again uh putting up just the
insane numbers that he always does 26 11
and six uh it's really going to be hard
not to
give him that award um again i think
especially after him winning the title i
think people are comfortable calling him
the best player in the league again
which whether or not that's actually
true uh i think the narrative sets up
for him to kind of make a run and take
it so i i like giannis at that plus 360
range
like that sam i i like that let me get
in the comments i want to see who they
are talking about uh
i got you
actually made you luca i see what you
did there shaq uh he has kevin durant
you the real mvp shout out to you you're
walking away with a hoodie my boy 23 ap
says embiid has been unstoppable and b
definitely has been unstoppable
uh rich dub says they can't stop him
doing anything and he improved his
shooting a lot becoming more dangerous
to other to know becoming more dangerous
to other things
to other teams uh i i think that he's
agreeing with you sam and talking about
giannis antetokounmpo uh
i'll jump in here i i think me
personally i think steph curry is gonna
win the mvp uh
but i don't think that i want to bet on
steph curry right now to win the mvp
i'll be honest sam uh i see
john marant down there john morant might
be worth a sprinkle they just went on a
winning streak he's been playing good
basketball
another num another name sam that i see
down there kevin durant
now now now hear me out
a run away a run away is all kevin
durant is i mean we were just talking
about him last month steph curry kevin
durant was the the two favorites so i
mean he's at plus 2400
take a sprinkle
i we know what basketball teams do after
the all-star break they turn it on kd
could be a run away a run away from
being the mvp so i i i think if i'm
worth if i'm taking a sprinkle i might
sprinkle on jaw sprinkle on kd and then
we will see we'll see if we get rich sam
we'll see if we get rich now let's talk
rookie of the year let's talk rookie of
the year kate cunningham just did an
interview with bleacher report
where he and he called himself he he
claimed he was
the best
rookie here's the graphic right here uh
where where kate said he felt like
he's the best rookie he said it sam
so do you agree
what's your take on rookie of the year
and let's pull up the yard so the people
at home can see
yeah i i don't i
i was not gonna be just uh take the
chalk with mvp i will do it for rookie
of the year i really like evan mobley
here i think not only is he i think he's
been the best rookie this year his
numbers are are fantastic the thing i
like most is the team he's on uh the
cavs have been the darling of the nba
and i think voters like to reward those
teams they like to leave an award season
saying uh the cavs got something and
they they're having an amazing year
unless they completely fall apart and
fall out of the playoff picture and all
that stuff which i don't think that's
gonna happen i think they're two or
three games out of the one seed they're
right up there so that's not happening
um i think this is mobley's award to
lose like cade caden is great but he
plays for one of the worst teams in the
league so how is he gonna make that jump
over evan mobley when they're playing
near the same level i just don't see it
so i like mobley
yeah i'm right there with you too sam i
think this is a runaway for mobley uh
cavaliers they're good you you you
talked about them they are a good team
and they will be in the playoff
contention mobley he's a a key piece of
their team uh so i could see him running
away with that get it now it's at -155
it might go up sooner or later i'm in
the comments though sam i'm in the
comments uh here we go
giddy at plus 1900 is an amazing spot
for a bet officially cooper uh shout out
to you that's funny you're walking away
with a hoodie um
i got one more in me i got one more
hoodie in me sam
i see i see k-way k-way says mobley
easily with a lot of uh
a lot of exclamation marks so shout out
to you uh finally sam let's see the odds
to win it all let's see the odds to win
it all
and
when the odds get up there sam what are
you thinking
what are you thinking here which way are
you leaning who are you putting your
money on
well i'm glad we're doing this at the
end of the show
because i'm probably going to lose the
audience here if i haven't already to be
honest um but i really like the jazz at
12 to 1. um
the thing that stands out to me most is
this is just a value play to me like
they have around the same odds as the
los angeles lakers who are not good
right now straight up um and you're
getting a jazz team it was the number
one offense in the sport their third and
overall net rating to me from a
narrative standpoint they remind me a
lot of the bucks from last year you had
three four years in a row where the
bucks were the best team in
in the regular season they had some
disappointing playoff finishes everyone
wrote them off said they were a regular
season team can't win at all yadda yadda
that created some value on them last
year they did end up winning the title i
feel that same way with the jazz this
year i think they should be priced right
around where the suns are at plus 800.
this team is really really good
they're so deep they have so much talent
and i also think the jazz probably
recognized that this is a really
important year for them so i wouldn't be
surprised to see them go make a move at
the trade deadline i mean if you're able
to get a team this good at the same
price as the lakers uh i think it's
crazy value so i love the jack
i like that sam i i i don't dislike your
bet
uh my thing is i it's just hard for me
to put money on the jazz because my
thing is do they have the superstar
power
to win in the playoffs we know in the
playoffs it's a lot of adjustments and
that's when the superstars come out to
play do the jazz have the superstars
power i don't know but i do know a team
that i feel confident in and i've been
saying it since the beginning and that's
the golden state warriors they went back
up sam they went back up
in the in uh
as the they're not the favorites anymore
they're not even close to me in the face
i mean they're second but they're far
away's away uh but
let's not talk warriors let's let's i
want to sprinkle it around i want to
sprinkle it around i want you guys can
we pull the graphic back up can we pull
the graph back up because i want to show
them a team that i'm talking about uh
that's on that graphic and there it is
you guys see the phoenix suns sitting at
plus 800
they were in the championship last year
they're the best team in basketball and
they're sitting at plus 800 i don't see
this being a bad bet sam i don't see
that one being a bad bet and i might
sprinkle my money on the phoenix suns uh
to win the championship
but sam i i think
i think that's it brother i i it's been
fun it's been fun but i i think that
that's it thank you guys for tapping
into the group chat presented by fanduel
remember what you learned
today
the indiana pacers pacers versus the
golden state warriors 3x2 is a lock the
sun's moneyline also
is a lock get on fanduel and tell our vr
betting same game parlay and pray for
sam
and it's jazz future we'll be back next
thursday with live moves giving out more
hoodies more jerseys and more locks if
you want a hoodie today
we will dm you not me or maybe sam might
sam mike he actually he's i told you
guys he's the he's the top of the social
team uh but i won't dmu br betting will
dm you so don't be alarmed alongside my
man sam richmond
i'm greg ivory we are leaving the group
chat
peace
[Music]
you